TO GET STARTED WITH THE UTILITY
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE HEARING
FOR WEDNESDAY AUGUST FIFTH I
HAVE SOME HOUSEKEEPING MATTERS
TO SORT OF MAKE MY WAY THROUGH
SO IF I COULD DO THAT. THEY
COME BACK AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. FIRST OF ALL I WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE HEARING. A BIT
DUE TO THE CONTINUED STATE HOME
ORDER. WE ARE PRO PAIN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN IT
DURING IN PERSON. PROSPER COURT
IN THE MASTER PHYSICAL DO SEEM
BE MAIN BY A- THE PUBLIC TEST
OF BROTHER HERE IN THE ROOM. OR
IN REMOTE- HEARING LOSS TIONS.
IF YOU NOT HAVE A MASS PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR TESTIMONY
TODAY. FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE
AND THE CHAMBERS IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMUM
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND LIMITED
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX BE THE-
SAME. ALSO DISTRICT DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS LIKE TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE
HERE IN THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WITH
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
REFER HAN AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. ATI
WOULD. THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU HAVE DONE
ONCE YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING TO
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL FONG
LIFTING THANK YOU LIMITING
ELEVATE USE TO ONE PERSON AT A-
TIME. WE ALSO WILL BE USING A
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE
THROUGHOUT WHICH ANY WITNESS
CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
AREA CODE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AGAIN THE CALL IN NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO. FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY UTILITY AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WELL AS TV
SCREEN YOUR CALL I AM PLAN TO
DO SO IT AUTHOR THE BILL YOUR-
BEGINNING THEIR BILL PRESENT.
THE OPERATOR ALIVE TO GIVE YOU
OPTIONS ON HOW TO KEEP ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. AND PLEASE WILL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS IS. A
LIFE BROADCAST AND YOU SMARTER
TO REDUCE THE STORE. PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT YOUR MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON LIFELINE NEED TO MUTE
YOUR PHONE TO YOUR CALL TO
SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO EIGHT
THREE. AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION. OUR
AFFECTED WITH BEFORE WE MOVE
THE BILLS ON THE COMMITTEE
AGENDA I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING OF SMITH'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GEN IBM
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY AND WE
WILL NOT HAVE A REPLACEMENT FOR
HIM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
WILL ALSO NOT BE OUR HEARING
TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOUR
CURRY WILL JOIN US FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. WE HAVE THREE GENDER
TO OUR CONSENT. AND WE HAVE
FILE ITEM ONE SB SEVEN OH TWO.
BY SENATOR HILL AND FILE ITEM
TO. S. B. U. ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
BY SENATOR HILL. TESTIMONY LET
ME- WE STILL NEED TO GET THE
STATUS OF CORE- TESTIMONY IS
LIMITED TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL
FOR EACH SIDE. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IS BRIEFLY STATE YOUR
NAME POSITION AFFILIATION AT
THIS TIME WITH THE RULES BEING
ESTABLISH WILL CALL THE MEETING
TO ORDER WILL LAST FOR ROLL
CALL. FIRST TRUST. HOLDEN
HOLDEN HERE PATTERSON PATTERSON
HERE BURKE BURKE HERE CORREO
FREE OUT HERE CUNNINGHAM.
AGUIAR-CURRY CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA. MAYES MAYES
HERE MURATSUCHI. FOR WILL WORK
HERE RIGHT YES. REYES HERE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HERE TANG
TANK HERE WE HAVE A FORM FOR A
BI AND ESTABLISH A MOTION IS IN
ORDER DR CORPORATE IN YOUR-
MOTION TO. IN A SECOND TO
APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. HOLDEN HOLDEN I
PATTERSON PATTERSON HI BURKE
BURKE HI RIO CARILLO HI
CUNNINGHAM. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY HI CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO
GARCIA. MAY MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK WORK HI RARES. REYES HI
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI TANG TANG
I. THE COMPUTERIZED. ELEVEN
NINE AND SIX OTHERS ADOPTED
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON
SENATOR HILL WE'RE ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO HAVE YOU JOIN US
AND SO WE'RE HERE TO.
PRESENTATION ON S. B. EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE BACCHARIS
EXCAVATIONS SUBSURFACE
INSULATION BEFORE JURORS. ALL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR VERY
MUCH AND COLLEAGUES. I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE CHAIR
FOR HEARING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE TODAY. THERE IS A
MOTION AND BEEN SECOND. BIGGEST
OF COURSE THE GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU I WOULD JUST TO WHICH
FOR THIS AND MEASURE TODAY'S AN
ISSUE OF INTO THIS BACK.
OPERATORS IN THE PUBLIC IN OUR
STATE. YOU FORGOTTEN. IN LOSS
OF PROPERTY AND LIFE I THINK
ALL OF THE MEMBERS ARE VERY
WELL AWARE. OF THIS ISSUE AND-
I WOULD BE IT SHOULD IN HEARING
FROM THE WITNESSES AT THIS
POINT. WE HAVE IF WE- DIRECTOR.
AND CHARLES LEGAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR I WILL CALL ON THE
PHONE MODERATE PHONE MODERATOR
JAMES WINGATE- IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE YOU CAN PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING WITH
THE CHAIR MY NAME IS DEAN
TWENTY EIGHT FROM THE USA NORTH
EIGHT ONE ONE. WHICH IS THE
REGIONAL NOTIFICATION CENTER
THAT IS THE PHONE TO FOR THE
ORGANIZATION TO CALL EIGHT ONE
ONE BEFORE YOU GET COVERED OR
OTHER TWO THIRDS CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM FINDING SOME OF THIS
BURKE YOU RE. AND THE BOTH
NOTABLE HAVE TO DO WITH THE WAY.
ABOUT REQUIRING FACILITY
OPERATORS TO- MAPPED THE NEW
INSTALLATIONS AND HAPPEN TO A
GISS MARC GEOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION SYSTEM- WE RELY ON
GIS SYSTEMS FOR EVERYTHING
THESE DAYS MANY PEOPLE WHO'VE
NEVER BEEN THE CAPITAL BEFORE
I. WOULD DONE. OR SOME WAY
ROUTE YOUR YEARS MORE TO GUIDE
YOU TO OKAY ALL THAT HAPPENED
THROUGH YOU CAN G. S. THANKS
OF THEIR UNDERGROUND AFTER IN
THIS WAY. THE FACILITIES. WHERE
CLUED UP. THE WIRE SOME TYPE OF
WAY IN WITH THE CAN BE LOW BUT
THAT IS NOT SPENT BUYING
CALIFORNIA Y. AND THEIR NUMBER
OF DAMAGES THAT HAPPEN EVERY
YEAR- IN IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY IN WHICH PHILIPPINES
THAT NOT ON THE MAPS ARE
DAMAGED AND SOMEBODY TO UPDATE.
THAT INFORMATION DIDN'T GET TO
THE FIELD. THAT THAT PART OF
THE- BILL BE INCLUDED IN MY
OPINION- THERE IS SOMETHING FOR
WHAT I CALL SQUISHING THEM IN
THE LANGUAGE- THAT DOESN'T
DEFINE WHO INSTALLATION THAT
THAT MANY ARE BEING DUP BRAND
PIPE THAT WASN'T PREVIOUSLY IN
ALBERTA. MEAN THIRTY FIFTH THAT
WOULD APPLY TO- REPAIR
RELOCATIONS REPLACEMENT OF THAT
NATURE. HI. A LANGUAGE DON'T DO
BECAUSE THE BETTER HAVE
SOMETHING IN THE LAW THAT WE TO
THIS TOPIC AND LET IT WORST
CASE OCCURRED THE- RIGHT ABOUT
WE WILL NOW HAVE BEEN SOLD FOR.
IN RELATION TO THAT WORKING SO
EVEN THOUGH OTHER PARTS ARE TO
THE WORDING OF THIS BILL.
DOESN'T PROVIDE THAT TO THE
OTHER DEFINITION OF NEW INTO. I
STILL THINK IT'S VALUABLE HAVE
A CLOSER THE OTHER PART THAT I
WANTED TO COMMENT ON- DEALS
WITH. I DON'T KNOW. OR WE TO
OUR DATABSE OF ALL THE RECORDS
FOR- A REQUEST MADE BY
EXCAVATORS TO- HAVE UTILITY
LANKY LOCATED WE HAVE GIVEN
FULL ACCESS TO STATE REGULATORS
ALREADY SUCH AS THE PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION PROJECT
REPORT THAT. ACCORDING WE DID
APPLE MORE THAN A YEAR IT BEEN
WORK GREAT. BUT IT MIGHT THEY
CAN'T PROVIDE IN. UNLESS HAVE A
FULL DATABASE THE ONE ARE NOT
SET UP BURCU A RETAIL NORFOLK
CENTERS ARE NOT UP TO PROVIDE
AND NOW. THE TICKETS ARE WILL
TO DEVELOP TAKE THE
TRANSMISSION AND DELIVERY. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE COMMUNICATE
SPEED TO COMMUNICATE A LINK
BETWEEN ACTIVATORS OF THE SOUL
OPERA. BUT WHEN. YEAH TWO ADULT
COME IN OUT TRêN THE COMPLY
DETERMINE A THERE'S A B. IN
THIS AND IN SUPPORT CORRECTIVE
FOR ALL THAT THE ROLE THE DIG
SAFE WORK TO MY FAMILY AND IT
IMPORTANT TO THE RE NOTE
CENTERS TO WITH THE TECHNICAL
PROVIDE FULL ACCESS TO ALL THE
TO GET. THE SO MY TESTIMONY
THIS TIME BUT I'VE HAD TO
ANSWER ANY THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE
ME OKAY WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENT I JUST WANNA ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES THAT THERE IS A TOTAL
OF FOUR MINUTES- FOR
PRESENTATION IN THIS INSTANCE
WE HAVE ONE MORE SPEAKER IN
SUPPORT- CHARLES HARVEY WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH THE
MONNING. OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME
CIRCA. OKAY FANTASTIC WELL GOOD
MORNING TEACHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS TRUMP
CARD AT THE FINAL BEHALF
BELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA CITY-
ACTIVATION. A FIRST CONTINUE TO
POSE THANK YOU READY TO
CALIFORNIA DUE TO INSUFFICIENT
COMMUNICATION THE LEAK CAN YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT EFFORT TO
PROMOTE BAKER ACTIVATION
PRACTICES THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL
SERVICES. WHICH TRAVEL THROUGH
UNDERGROUND STRUCTURE THE MAIN
BASE AND OPERATIONAL ONE
NOTABLY SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE OF
OPERATORS THE MAP. INFORMATION
WHICH I HAVE. I'M GEN THREE ONE
TWELVE TWENTY THREE. I HAVE
BEEN MAINTAIN THE CURRENT
RECORD OF OPERATOR. THERE'S
NOTHING WILL TO UNDER PUSHED
STATE AND THEREBY PUT ACTIVE
FROM HAVE. BELIEVE COMMONSENSE
REFORMS THAT YOU KNOW WILL NOT
ONLY SAVE LIVES BUT WHAT THE
BAY CITY MONEY THE TRACKING
DOWN. THE STRUCTURE AND- THAT
MIGHT. BE HAVE BEEN ABOUT THE
BET DE TO OPEN IN THE TRIPLE
MEASURE THAT THE BIG FAKE FOR
THE ABLE FROM THE OFFICE THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO BE OUT OF
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY.
WHICH WOULD ONLY BETTER IT OUR
VIEWPOINT WITH THE BOARD'S
OPERATE FUNCTION BUT WITHOUT
THE BOTH THEIR CRITICAL
COMMUNICATION TO ENSURE. AT THE
BASIN PRACTICALLY WHY REALLY
I'M IT ALL UP WE CAN BARELY
BREATHE THE OBVIOUS CONTINUE
EFFORTS TO STRENGTHEN UDATE.
CRACK CAL AND WOULD URGE COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
COMMENT WE DON'T SO. IF THERE'S
ANYONE. SEEING NONE ARE WE MOVE
TO THE PHONE THERE NOW OPEN FOR
DISH WITNESSES AND SO. OF PHONE
MY- WE'RE GOING TO HEAR NAY.
ORGANIZATION YOUR POSITION ON
OF SUPPORT ON THE BILL SO PHONE
MONITOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON.
TO TESTIFY I IN SUPPORT. I
LEADER GERMAN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND WE WILL
GO TO MY TWENTY EIGHT. YOU
MISTER MEMBERS REID WITH READ
THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON
BEHALF OF DESERT WATER AGENCY
IN SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A COUPLE
MORE QUEUING UP. OUR NEXT
PERSON IS ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I'M DONE WITH THE
AMERICAN SUBCONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION BEING HUNDREDS OF
SUBCONTRACTING COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING EXCAVATORS
AND LANDSCAPERS. PART OF S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE PERSONNEL LIKE
THAT THAT HELP FOR SEVERAL
SAFETY MEASURES HE'S OUT THERE
IN THE PAST BALLING BALCONIES
LIMOUSINE HIRE POSITION BILLS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE WILL
GO TO LIKE TWENTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS GREAT WAY IN A
CITY ENGINEER WITH THE CITY OF
SAN CARLOS AND THEN CARLOS IS
IN SUPPORT OF THAT EIGHT SIXTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. NO THE
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUED UP.
THANK YOU WILL PROMOTE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY
WITNESS- IN OPPOSITION
TESTIFYING IN PERSON TODD BLOOM
STAYING WITH THE PARTICULAR YOU
MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY
FROM A DOLLAR. LET'S JUST LET'S
MAKE SURE YOUR MIKE IS IN
SUPPORT OF.
I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE MIKE IS WORKING JUST YET.
YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME MISTER
CHAIR I THINK SO THANK YOU I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS TODD BLOOM STEIN FOR
THE UNDERGROUND SERVICE ALERT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COMMONLY
CALLED AND DECLARE. THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING DURING
THE PANDEMIC. YOUR LEADERSHIP
FOR OUR STATE IS GREATLY NEEDED
TO DURING THESE TRYING TIMES.
SECONDLY IT SHOULD BE STATED IN
UNEQUIVOCAL TERMS THAT SENATOR
HILL IS WORKS TIRELESSLY IN
THIS POLICY AREA. WE ARE MOST
THANKFUL FOR HIS EFFORTS AT
PROTECTING THE LIVES OF THOSE
THAT WORK AND LIVE HUNDRED
YEARS BROWN INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEN YOUR HILL YOUR EFFORTS
SAVE THE LIVES. WITH REGARDS TO
S. B. EIGHT SIXTY FIVE DIGGER
ALERT HAS ADOPTED AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. ARC
AND WITH THE BILL EXISTS WITH
THE STATE COMPELLING DIG ALERT
WHICH IS AN UNREGULATED NON
PROFIT MUTUAL BENEFIT
CORPORATION. TO RELINQUISH ITS
NOTIFICATION TICKETS TO THE
STATE. INSTEAD WE BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD REQUIRE THE
STATE TO WORK COOPERATIVELY AND
PARTNER WITH DICK ALERT. LAST
YEAR DICK FIELDED EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND CONTACTS FOR
SERVICE. THOSE SERVICE REQUESTS
GENERATED ABOUT EIGHT AND A
HALF MILLION THAT UTILITY AND
NOTIFICATION TICKETS.
PRESUMABLY THE DATA FROM THOSE
EIGHT AND A HALF MILLION ANNUAL
TICKETS WILL BE USED TO FORM
EDUCATION AND ENFORCEMENT
STRATEGIES AT THE DIG SAFE PORT.
BUT ACCORDING THE DIG SAFE
BOARDS TWENTY NINETEEN
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW. THERE ARE
ONLY FIVE INVESTIGATORS IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION.
THOSE FIVE INVEST CREATORS
WOULD HAVE TO REVIEW. SEVEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE TICKETS PER DAY. TO
REVIEW ALL EIGHT AND A HALF
MILLION TICKETS IN A YEAR. WE
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDERING AMENDMENTS THAT
ENCOURAGES A COOPERATIVE AND
PARTNERING APPROACH INSTEAD OF
THE MANDATE CONTAINED IN THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE. WE HAVE
PROVIDED SUCH LANGUAGE TO THE
AUTHOR BUT HE HAS BEEN
REJECTED. WE WILL OF COURSE
CONTINUE TO PURSUE TO FIGHT THE
PA SOLUTIONS. GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. I WILL TURN
TO THE PHONE MODERATOR WE ARE
LOOKING FOR WITNESSES ON THE
LINE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL. AGAIN
THESE WILL BE. FILIATION AND
THE POSIION OF OPPOSITION. TO
COMMENT ON OPPOSITION FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR W. SKILLING UP AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE THAT'S OF DISCUSS
THE QUESTION THAT'S A TWEENER
EITHER. I MEAN IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THAT IS ONLINE.
MODERATOR NOBODY IS GOING UP.
NOBODY IS GOING UP AT THIS TIME
SIR OKAY WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS SENATOR HILL. C.
NINE. SENATOR HILL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO IN YOUR CLOTHES-
RESPOND TO THE OPPOSITION AND
OR- ARE CONCERNED WITH
ADDRESSING THE AMENDMENT.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- WITH THE WITH
RESPECT TO THE OPPOSITION. WHAT
I FIND IS IT THAT I'M
STRUGGLING WITH AND CANNOT
UNDERSTAND WHY THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA UNDERGROUND'S LEARN.
THIS NOTICE CENTER NO PROBLEM
WITH THE BILL IS MORE THAN
HAPPY TO BUY PERMISSION IS
NECESSARY- THAT IS NEEDED IN
ORDER TO DEVELOP AND LOOK AT
THE ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS. OF THE
DICKENS THAT ARE CAUSING
PROBLEMS. LOSS OF LIFE IN IS.
THE IS THAT THE NOTIFICATION
TICKETS THAT GO TO THE STATE
THAT SHOULD GO TO THE STATE AND
ALLOW THE- FOR TWO OF THE WAY
ALL OF THESE TO THEY CAN
EDUCATE APPROPRIATELY. THE DATE.
THERE ARE PRO OR PROBLEM AREAS
FOR PROBLEM INSTITUTIONS THAT
ARE CAUSING THOSE UNSAFE BIG
APPROACHES SO I FIND IT STRANGE
THAT IT'S THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. UNDERGROUND SERVICE
ALERT IS HAVING THE PROBLEM.
ACTUALLY I'M WONDERING. WHAT
ARE THEY TRYING TO HIDE. OR WHO
ARE THEY TRYING TO PROTECT BY
NOT PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE COLLEAGUES
THINK. THE MOTION OF SENATOR IF
I COULD JUST VERY QUICKLY I
THINK IF WE DID HAVE- OTHER MEN
READ THAT YOU WERE WORKING WITH
STAFF ON IT. PRECIADO YOU DOING
SO ABOUT A MEMBER OF THE N.
ALL. WITH REGIONAL GROUND
ALLIANCE. THAT IS IN A MINUTE
TO HAVE INDICATED THAT YOU'RE.
KAREN WE AND STAFF HAS BEEN
HELPFUL WITH THAT AND YOU AS
WELL MISTER CHAIR AT THIS LATE
HOUR BECAUSE THAT- SUGGESTED
CAME IN I THINK THE LAST SHOW
WE APPRECIATE YOU ADDRESS IT IS
STILL MOVE OR TO- TO
APPROPRIATE. WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THAT BURGER. SO THE
MOTION. DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATE AND THE AMENDMENT
WOULD BE TAKEN UP AND
APPROPRIATIONS THERE'S A MOTION
SPEND MAY DO I MADE AND
SECONDED BARBARA. PROCREATE
HOLDEN FIVE HOLDEN HI PATTERSON
PATTERSON HI BURKE BURKE HI
CORREO A. L. HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM MARK CURRY. WHY A
CURRY I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA HI MAYES
MAYES I MURATSUCHI. FOR FOUR
FIVE RAYOS REYES HI SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI TEAM. TEN FIVE.
THIRTEEN MOTION CARRIES- WITH
THIRTEEN I THINK THOSE ARE ALL
MEMBERS WHO AVAIL. CASH IN ON.
THE ROLE OF THE MOTION CARRIES
THIRTEEN- WE'RE GOING TO UPHOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR MR MURATSUCHI
WHO IS ON HIS WAY AND TO ADAM
THANK YOU MEDICARE THANK YOU
CALLING VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS. NOW. YEAH MEDIA. YEAH
YEAH.
I HAVE. YEAH. WE WILL
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE THOSE. RIGHT
NOW ALL. OKAY. WE. WITH ONE
DEVICE HERE- YEAH HE'S YEAH NO
WORRIES. OKAY WE'RE TO MAKE OUR
WAY BACK THROUGH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON
TO CONSPICUOUS. MEDICAL OR CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSENT CALENDAR
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
EDUARDO GARCIA. MERECE SU CHI.
WE WILL HOLD THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OPEN TO ALLOW MR
GARCIA TO COME IN AND ADD ON TO
THAT WILL MOVE ON TO. SB. EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE. MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I. THE MOBILE. AT
THE. I'M READY. THE FOURTEENTH.
SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE HAS
FOURTEEN VOTERS THAT BILL IS
OUT. YEAH HERE TO.
OKAY LET'S
GO BACK TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEMS REAL QUICK CONSENT
CALENDAR EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA I. OKAY WE HAVE FOURTEEN
VOTES IN FAVOUR OF CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT COMPLETES THE
BUSINESS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
TODAY RICHARD.